bonsoir mettre au vert
on a l'impression que derrière ça c'est
vraiment une vision de la justice qui
est très différente de celle des
conservateurs au gouvernement harper de
2011 qui a été débattu entre les juges
de la cour suprême
est ce une décision unanime aussi
qu'est-ce que vous décoder derrière ça
vous avez raison de dire qu'il ya eu une
profonde réflexion on prédit juge parce
que si on retourne un petit peu en
arrière à l'époque où le juge antonio
lamer était juge en chef il y avait une
fonction sur la façon d'interpréter de
façon équilibrée cette disposition alors
à ce que 12 la charte des droits et il
n'y avait pas nécessairement une espèce
d'unité qui rejoignait tous les juges
alors alors on s'aperçoit qu'au pasteur
du temps on a commencé et évidemment il
ya des niveaux jugés d'un coup on a
commencé à s'intéresser davantage à sa
disposition là-haut lui donner plus de
portes et on le fait en 2016 quand on a
rejeté la validité de certaines peines
minimales
ensuite le gouvernement fédéral après
les volets il a fait un projet de loi
pour s'attaquer aux peines minimales et
là vous avez le summum c'est à dire la
cour suprême qui exulte à de prendre une
position uniforme et cesser la vertu de
ce jugement là au moins il n'y a pas d'
indécision au pot les citoyens auraient
juristes pour les tribunaux on connaît
les règles du jeu maintenant et s'est
clarifiée oui et au coeur de sa vraiment
c'est le concept qu'un individu doit
avoir une chance de se réhabiliter
finalement oui et pour asseoir
solidement c'est un avis visent le lac
où se réfère à ce qu'on appelle le
concept d imiter
cherchez pas dans la charte des droits
la mention de
ce concept là ça n'existe pas mais la
cour dit il reste quand même que
condamner quelqu'un à mourir en prison
sap a un sacré coup à la dignité de la
personne et on prouve que c'est
contraire ne pas lui donner une petite
couverture ou mousse et 25 habitations
sur la possibilité de retourner dans
l'assistanat lastours avec les citoyens
vivent une vie normale et c'est ça qui
le concept c'est un concept très à la
mode depuis qu'on s'intéresse à mourir
dans la dignité il ya eu beaucoup de
chemin a été parcouru
et j'ai l'impression que la cour suprême
a profité de l'occasion pour dire ça
c'est un concert important qu'on veut
lui donner du tonus mais il faut aussi
comprendre que c'est pas automatique la
libération au bout de 25 ans on a le
droit de faire une demande au bout de 25
ans mais ça veut pas dire que ont vaqué
c'est notre demande et ça veut pas dire
comme certains le redoutent que des
criminels vont se retrouver dans la rue
par la suite ah non vous avez raison de
le souligner c'est très important de le
rappeler il quand on regarde l'histoire
pénil de nouveaux grands criminels au
canada je pense par exemple à robin
pecten encore en revue danic qui a causé
la mort de toc toc femmes autochtones il
a été je sais pas combien de fois devant
la commission des libérations
conditionnelles et à chaque fois sa
demande a été refusée à jeter et je
pense également à d'autres grands
criminels à toronto il ya eu plusieurs
la bernardo en trois autres ont toujours
rejeté ouais les dames en sont toujours
rejetée est bon ça veut pas et qu'elles
le seront toutes un jour si quelqu'un
comme visionnaire qui était très jeune
quand les incidents se sont produits va
évidemment mature et évolué et dans 20
56 je suis convaincu que ce ne soit plus
le même homme point donc les
commissaires de
cette époque nous aurons à réviser son
dossier à examiner ces salles espoir de
vie ses seules limites et ouais quand
vous entendez les conservateurs dit on
trouve ça décevant pour les victimes
cette décision là on n'est pas d'accord
avec la décision de la cour suprême
quelle est votre réaction parce que
c'est comme si on opposait les victimes
et il le criminel et son droit de faire
une réflexion sur ce qui le fait et
éventuellement de changer et peut-être
éventuellement un jour d'être libéré
la cour d'appel du québec qui avait
rendu gras jugement bien l'étoffé sur
cette question là il arrive directement
sur le sujet en disant c'est pas une
objectif valable que de faire de la
vengeance si on veut venger la douleur
des victimes des familles des victimes
il s'est passé pas l'objectif noble d'un
fiction d'une bonne surtout 22 25 alors
alors on peut faire de la justice privée
en civ mais la justice répartie qui va
jusqu'à la vengeance ses parts dans la
culture canadienne alors c'est pour ça
qu'on dit dans le fond derrière tout ça
c'est une question de valeurs c'est très
important ça définit qui nous sommes
aussi comme canadienne mais oui c'est ça
c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs la cour
suprême utilise cette expression là
c'est une valeur fondamentale que le
respect de la dignité des citoyens
qu'ils soient malades ou qu'ils soient
devenus et et rappelons nous que
l'expectative de vie normale des
citoyens pour les hommes 81 à les femmes
82 ans s'attendent à 61 chez les
personnes qui sont détenues donc si vous
voulez dire bah écoutez ça vaut la peine
de continuer
à vous battre en détention qu'on
surveillait et n'a pas vous déprimer et
ne pas vous suicider mais je veux dire
penser que dans au bout de 25 à y avoir
peut-être la lumière au bout du tunnel
parce que sinon c'est l'équivalent d'une
finalement mais si on regarde la très
belle en terminant les gens ça peut
affecter parce qu'on comprend bien le
principe il ya des criminels
actuellement qui ont reçu ces peines
cumulatives alors on envoie quelques uns
à l'écran le justin bourque
monsieur hollande aussi à l'art y en a
d'autres aussi benjamin hudon barbeau
des gens qui ont su les peines très
longue mais là il va devoir y vont
devoir faire une demande pour qu'on
révise leur peine
oui absolument au bout de vingt cinq ans
ils auront à une demande à formuler et
encore ils sont jugés sur la qualité des
dossiers qui vont présenter la
commission des liqueurs libération
conditionnelle et son comprend qu'il ya
faute d'automatismes
c'est pas parce que vous avez fait vingt
cinq ans que là ça va bien vous avez
libéré il faudra beaucoup plus que ça
pour convaincre ces gens là qui mérite
de retourner dans la société merci
beaucoup pour cette analyse m hébert
merci au revoir au revoir